hey I'm slash and one of my all-time
favorite movies is The Exorcist
when I was really really young I just
gravitated towards horror and thrillers
and sci-fi first time I saw The Exorcist
was in the back of the Volkswagen in a
drive-in theater and I was really
fascinated more than scared it is very
much like a roller coaster ride
I love the tension the adrenaline rush
you know your heart starts pounding and
you really get sucked into the drama of
it but it's the ride that's so exciting
and I have I ended up having a huge
crush on Linda Blair from that that's
just so wrong a really great score
becomes as much of a character in the
movie as the actual physical human
beings to build bells is such a hooky
melody and it was so perfectly creepy
for the Exorcist itself and it's one of
the premiere examples of how a really
good piece of music can be an essential
character in the film because I think
that's what makes a great horror movie
is the stuff that you don't see one
thing that I do with music that is akin
to what happens for me in horror movies
there is a whole sort of explosive
element where they're waiting for the
show to start and then the lights go out
and there's that whole sort of release
that happens there because of all the
tension that built up and then you come
out and there is an explosive sort of
surge of energy and you ride that
there's sort of ebb and flows of that
all throughout the show and that
definitely is a similar element in
horror movies that I really relate to
because there's a musician in this crazy
business that I'm and suspense is a
major part of the whole game but I think
that horror movies always provided a
certain kind of thrill that comes out of
the suspense that I thrive on
time slash and I love movies that's a
wrap